foreign
made you know whatever amount of
millions of dollars
I had a profound realization like when I
go out to eat
with a friend who's a billionaire of me
you and Travis were sitting around or me
you and Matt mullenweg were sitting
around and we took out our net worth and
it was like oh my God like you and I are
down here these two guys are up here we
all go and have a steak
steak tastes the same we all go and go
skiing or we go to Japan
same experience and once I realized that
I was like for me it might be different
for other people
the scorecard of cash doesn't matter
yeah Beyond a certain point and for me
it was the freedom to do whatever I want
in my life and to take care of my three
daughters take care of my wife and be a
good provider take care of my extended
family if they needed some help on the
margins and once that happened I was
like I actually
I drive a model y
and I prefer that to the plaid and I
have a model X like I enjoy sometimes in
New York strip better than wagu I just
kind of like the flavor of it it's a
fifth of the price so once you start to
realize like okay this is these are just
contracts and money is just not the
right scorecard yeah the right score
card is did you wake up and couldn't get
couldn't wait to get out of bed like to
me that's the true score I cannot wait
to get on air and do this week in
startups with Molly and talk about tech
can't wait to meet with Founders I can't
wait to teach another course on how to
start a company can't wait to see my
friends for dinner can't wait to help my
friends if they're in need can't wait to
come on the Tim first box if I can't
wait to do the activity I know I'm doing
something right when you invited me on I
went to Jade I was like my wife's name
is Jade and I was like oh you know Tim
invited me on the pockets I can't wait
to do it like and I have never that that
very rarely happens but I was like you
know I'd listen to the Tim Ferriss
podcast all the time and I'm sure at
some point I'll be on it but the act of
doing it with you to me was like oh I'm
excited you know and
being excited and enthusiastic to me it
just means something has aligned yeah
you know when I'm writing you and I have
the same thing I don't know where it is
for you but somewhere around like a
third of the book things start heating
up for me and like you all of a sudden
like you know the first third of the
book is like oh and then all of a sudden
oh yeah I know what sections I have to
do I can see behind the next Corner the
book just flows and you're like boom 2
000 words are coming out at a clip you
know like those kind of moments when you
have that flow and you have that
enthusiasm for life
you have to construct the life around
those and then life is just pulling you
out of bed every day and just telling
you like
oh I gotta go to bed like every night I
go to bed and I'm just like I don't want
to close my eyes I want to just do
another hour it's hard for me to go to
bed sometimes because my enthusiasm is
so high for life and
you know it wasn't always that way a lot
of it was a struggle a lot of it was
trying to figure out who I was but I
really do want to enjoy
this last couple of Decades of if
there's an interesting project or moment
that's going to create that great memory
and going to make me enthusiastic I want
to do it yeah and if you know that means
helping out a friend on a special
project or you know going on a friend's
podcast or whatever doing a new podcast
it's just I feel very blessed that I got
here and I want to just squeeze every
single drop of juice out of that you
know box of oranges
really I mean think about it our friend
Dave Goldberg rest in peace you know
Tony Shea yeah the darkness there like
it can be over and it can be it's
exactly like our age range where we
start saying goodbye to people yep and
so if you're in your 20s or 30s like
you're just on adrenaline and then you
get to 40s and 50s and you're like huh
what do I do with what's left especially
if some things have hit for you you know
like if you're Tim Ferriss and like you
got to really start thinking like okay
well I'm one of the top podcasters in
the world one of the top authors in the
world is this actually making me happy
yeah right and that's the thing I'm
writing in my new book about is my new
book is about money and wealth and um
can't wait to read it I want to send you
some early stuff and get your thoughts
on it but I'm writing about this Paradox
that you and I are talking about right
now which is what happens when you catch
the car yeah what happens you know it's
it's part how do you catch the car
but then once I get you on the hook for
that like how do you get the money
now what happens when you have caught
the car and then now you have to look in
the mirror
I caught the car look at the adrenaline
rush is over
what am I actually happy did I want to
catch that car yeah did I want to beat
him first did I want to be Jake owl did
I want to be Travis did I want to be
Matt Molly wag yeah is this actually
making me happy what now and that's
where like Buddhism and a lot of like
soulfulness has hit me in my 50s or you
know right before my 40s basically when
my two friends died two of my poker
buddies died and it just it just
reprogrammed my brain in a major way you
know those two events and it's actually
been a gift
you know in a way because now I just
look at the world differently so it's a
big guess things in perspective yeah I
mean it does really yeah and you know
another pattern I've noticed just with
respect to catching the car is that
not everyone but a lot of a lot of
achievers I know who
have been driven enough
and worked hard enough and focused long
enough and sacrificed enough to make a
lot of money when they finally crossed
that threshold where they're where they
they can't really rationalize the need
to make more right which by the way I
mean I mean not to plug my own I haven't
done this I haven't mentioned the four
hour work week in a long time but if
you've actually read some of the basics
the fundamentals in that book it
outlines just how
much self-deception goes into believing
that you need 20 30 50 100 million
dollars it's mostly unjustifiable
totally and
when you get enough money that you've
won the game you always thought would
answer your prayers and remove all the
pain anxiety and depression and it
doesn't yeah that is a terrifying moment
and oh my god do people and I'll include
myself in this group of people yeah
begin to panic because you're like wait
a second if that didn't fix these things
yep what well what in the [ __ ] am I
supposed to do and uh it could be and
you know I don't want to make it a
complete swan song I mean look it's it's
better to all things being equal to have
the money than to not have the money
however
the prevalence of depression in
quote unquote successful people that has
increased rather than decreased after
they catch the car is it's worth
studying I think it tells us a lot about
The Human Condition even if you never
end up catching the car